había bastante emoción sobre todo por
parte de los hinchas Ecuatorianos que
vienen llenaron toda una parte de atrás
de uno de los arcos en este bellísimo
estadio adentro es bellísimo ese estadio
por fuera también pero de verdad que un
estadio bastante moderno ese techo
retráctil Cómo se vivió con muchísima
emoción por parte de los Ecuatorianos
habían había una parte de hinchas de
Qatar Y es que no dejaron de alentar a
su selección a lo largo de este partido
pero eso es cierto que pues la tribuyó
de principio a fin en este partido con
esos dos goles por cero Enner Valencia
era el que se esperaba no El capitán de
este equipo que pues logra este doblete
en un muy buen partido en el que él pues
brilló sobre todo en el primer tiempo
muy buen ritmo por parte de Ecuador y
sobre todo pues eh catar Que
prácticamente nunca vio la pelota sobre
todo en el primer tiempo y ya en el
segundo Pues los cataríes eh de de de de
de digamos que lograron encontrar un
poquito más de espacios llegaron a largo
un par de veces con un poco de
peligrosidad pero pues Ecuador fue mucho
más dominante técnicamente muy superior
muchísimos problemas también tenía el
guardameta de
Qatar al con muchísimos errores sobre
todo en despeje y esto pues le ha pasado
factura Entonces les decía en el
Valencia que marcó un primer gol al
minuto 16 un penalti y luego ya sobre el
minuto 31 vino otro gol un muy buen gol
de cabeza tras un excelente paso de pase
depreciado preciado que hizo un
excelente partido y hubiera podido ser
un triplete de hecho pero fue un gol
anulado sobre el minuto 3 al todo con
puro comienzo de este partido